yeah continue then Allison if you decide
to engage faith in all these processes
that are going on how do you make people
basically how do you prevent people from
saying that we got is on my side and
sort of using that as a basis for
division and instead of you know using
faith as the force of good and just
remaining it as a force of them I mean I
think that that and there will always be
a debate about what is God's will and
people will debate that and have most
fierce debate about it and and that
would happen within a religious faith
never mind between faiths I think it is
only dangerous when you see God's will
defined by your faith which excludes the
other faith in other words that you
don't it is positive it is actually
inimical to your faith to have another
faith exist in the in the in the same
space with the same right to express
itself you see what I mean so you you
know you will never get out of debating
you know if you are someone of faith
what does God want what should we do you
will never get out of that debate within
a faith number line between the face I
think what is what is dangerous is when
it becomes a means of NSSA excluding the
other person
because their faith is not the same as
yours does that make sense so in other
words one is about you know your your
religion and the other is a broader
debate that will always happen about
what God's will is